while xbox one and ps4 owners have been
crying foul over potentially downgraded
graphics in watch dogs there's no such
worry for PC players so long as they're
rocking an NVIDIA GPU I'm mark Walton
and this is the news in the new trailer
for Ubisoft upcoming open-world hackfest
engineer paul glassy talks about how
Nvidia and Ubisoft Montreal have worked
together to add the hardware makers HBA
Oh plus technology designed to create
more realistic shadows and it's fancy TX
AAA anti-aliasing effects and I only
look at it I mean just look at it look
at that vote you ever seen a guy fishing
with such ridiculous clarity before and
lights and shadows don't you just want
to get in there and touch them maybe rub
them all over your face and a
deliciously gratuitous display of shadow
base for play or not whatever your call
still you're going to need quite the rig
to see such sexy the light Ubisoft
recently let loose the pc specs with a
game which calls for a minimum of a
quad-core cpu six gigabytes of ram and
at least an nvidia gtx 460 or radeon HD
5770 and if you want to see the game at
its absolute best you will need at least
an i seven or eight core AMD cpu 8
gigabytes of ram and a gtx 560 or HD
7850 is your pc up to the task of
running watch dogs will you be upgrading
to get the very best out of it let us
know in the comments below and for more
on uber soft latest games check out
gamespot